hello obviously already know the topic
my name is Susana and I'm working for
f-secure for over two years I'm also a
coordinator of post chapter form and
machine learning and data science this
is a very big data science community
post nine and I'm primarily interested
in LP NLP data visualization and
storytelling and probably some of you
already know what I figure is it's a big
cybersecurity company one of the biggest
or the biggest in Europe we have offices
all over the world and also hearing or
so and in Poznan and we offer variety of
products obviously connected with
cybersecurity and in today I'm going to
talk about our idea for common line
language
what cyber what use cases do we have for
it and how we created it and what
challenges we had during our research
project and also in this presentation
I'm going to explain all of the or most
of the cyber security related topics and
definitely I will give definitions and
also you will see IPs
but they are going to be sullen demised
also names are going to be nice because
we want to protect our data
so in particular we deal with so we call
it events but there are some
dictionaries with logs actually of what
happens on computers devices of our
customers and in such locks we also have
common line executions as you can see in
the middle of the screen
so these are our fret hunters amazing
people they are sitting in this amazing
nice alike room 24/7 and they are
rising the Hawks coming from their
devices from our customers and for them
common line it's like it's a baby bread
let's say so let's imagine that you are
a fred hunter and you come up with such
a common line does anyone know what it
actually is see and that's why I came to
this data science conference with this
talk and not a cybersecurity because now
I'm the badass and I can tell you so
this is actually this is actually an
execution of a reverse shell with this
problem and what it does so when the
attacker uses this command it he or she
actually gains like he or she can use
your interactive shell to do many bad
things on your computer but actually it
is really hard to like detect using for
example a firewall because it's called a
reverse shell so it's actually
connection not going from an attacker to
the host computer to the computer that
is being attacked but actually it
invokes it creates a connection from the
computer that is being attacked to so it
is an outgoing connection so it's really
hard to spot on whether for example
firewall because firewalls usually
protect from incoming connections this
is an example of a different kind of how
we can invoke a reverse shell and
actually these are two comments and the
second one is like it's not very
suspicious maybe but when the first one
is fired up some time before it and
those two are very dangerous actually
and what about this comment what do you
think about it oh this is a good
comments right we are using it every day
but there is this - age and this - P
password to localhost what is it
so actually this is a very good
situation and in real life example I
would say that well the sentence my
dumplings are blue well something is off
right the time things shouldn't be blue
maybe they are dyed so there's some like
food dye and they are safe to eat but
still blue dumplings is very weird so in
this example we have our usage of very
different very normal command git commit
but actually after that we have
something weird and something is off and
we this is anomaly we want to see it we
want to detect it and this comment is
actually not very suspicious not
suspicious at all it's a thing but when
it's fired out on a computer of an HR or
an accountant is very suspicious because
an HR people from HR or accountants
shouldn't use on a daily basis such a
comment so in a real-life example
imagine that someone dressed as your
parents comes to your home and says
hello this is a dinner for you and then
maybe does some ninja moves it's weird
it's not your parents something's off
also so in cyber security we really
really want to detect such cases
something uncommon some anomalies we
want to detect usage of IP sports
commands and environment variables for
example to be able to say something is
off we want to detect usage of uncommon
or invalid flag and flag venues and
detect uncommon behavior and obviously
we could use reg ex reg access to detect
IPS or ports or environment variables
but predictions don't always work
believe me it's a tedious work to create
like working reg X for that also and
when looking for invalid facts and come
on flag values it's really hard to like
parse all of it we imagine that you have
like millions of logs millions of common
lines and you're trying to
like make a dictionary of it or analyze
it with set of rules if and then rules
it's really hard so here we can think
about NLP because common lines they
follow are some kind of structure they
so we can think about them as sentences
when we want to detect usage of IP ports
etc we can think about named entities
recognition when we would like to detect
usage of uncommon on average facts we
could tark common glanced with some sort
of parts of speech so to say and analyze
it further and we could also another
series of common lines if we treat them
as sentences and like order them with
the time order and parse it as text so
here comes common line language where an
opinion cybersecurity means so I was
using Spacey for my own personal
projects and obviously install Spacey
and you download some models prepared by
Spacey for English for Polish for German
and you have some sort of part of speech
target organizer pre-trained named
entity recognition model you can read
additional additionally train it and use
it for your own purposes but actually we
did a small research over the Internet
and we saw that there is no such like
framework for common lines so we decided
to do it especially for Linux commands
because that was actually our decision
we are using it on a daily basis so it
was easy for us to start with that and
we decided to gather the data and then
create some tokenizer
and I'll take the data train part of
speech tagger and train named entities
model and this is our proof of concept
for seemly like :
so the data obviously we have our data
we have our logs but there are a lot of
unknown commands so because they're very
company specific so all of you create
some of your own some of your own apps
program scripts so there were commands
that we didn't know and on the internet
there was no information about it so we
had to deliver it somehow there were a
lot of errors in the logs so imagine
that you were typing something and like
every my in my history of the command
line
logs every third command is an error
because I made some typos and we have
typos and some like I'm buddy ordered
dragon flag values in our laws and also
we had problems with gathering
representative sample because the data
we have comes from usually from admins
or from developers and it's also
filtered filtered out at some point so
we don't have like normal usage of
normal commands like find crap cut so we
wanted to normalize our data set of it
and we use enough to bash data set so
the researchers try to do parse from
English language to like there was an
English sentence and they were trying to
create commands that we're going to do
the job for it so in the data set we
have such example of search the regular
files of the current directory tree
fostering gerado
and we have multiple solutions annotated
created by the experts on how to do it
so we used part of this data set because
it contained all of very simple commands
like find like echo like L sing like
which etcetera etcetera and there comes
tokenization and you would think that is
actually very simple because you just
split by space right well not always
sometimes you have records or records
like strings for example in sets and you
shouldn't
by spaces inside the red X so you have
to detect it and sometimes we wanted to
xsplit flag and flag various and pursued
them differently for example for parts
of speech tagging but flag and fact
values were connected so no space in
between or equal sign in between so we
also had to tokenize somehow so we
decided to use bash legs which is
open-source Python parser for bash but
it's it doesn't have a full support for
complicated parameter expansions and it
doesn't handle less popular unknown
comments well and as I told you before
we have a lots of them so we decided to
tokenize with bash legs and then
additionally tokenize with our own
additional recognizer
we're just splitting back chosen
characters so how organisations looks
like in our case for part of speech
tagging it was simple we were splitting
by spaces or how the bosch nexxt decided
but then if we wanted when we wanted to
go with named entity recognition we
define that IPS could be an identities
and here we have an example so it was
tokenized by bash legs and we see that
IP shows up in one of the tokens but
actually it's a part of the token and we
would like to talk only this IP parts
not the whole token so we thought about
it just like with compound words we have
a lot of them in German compound words
our words that are made up from
different words and I really like part
is equally important and gives some
information carries some information so
we have the word that's looks like which
is made from Daffy logo and that's like
and this is a fine thing so obviously an
airplane so we did the same we just
split it by chosen characters further to
four named entity recognition and here
comes eight annotations you can imagine
it was a tedious but amazing work
had to do it twice once for part of
speech tagging once for named entity
recognition
it was manual and it took write expert
knowledge a magazine we used a really
great tool da kana which is an open
source text annotation tool and this is
how it looks like but to simplify our
work a bit we implemented annotation
feedback loop so here is our animator
and he or she looks at the data and
tries to annotate it so when we got our
annotation for several documents for
several examples like 100 or 200 or even
several hundreds of them we decided to
train a very simple part of speech or an
entity recognition model and we know it
was going to make mistakes because it
like not enough data it wasn't going to
be perfect but still we annotated every
other example with it and then feed it
pre annotated examples for the
annotators so they can verify that it is
correct or fix it and here comes the
loop so here actually this is a DoCoMo
with part of speech already target
already annotated and so we decided to
help our annotators a bit and split the
sentence or the command line by tokens
so every token was not different and a
separate line so here she just had to
mark one line and annotated and we
defined parts of speech such as commands
supplements flags and obviously flag
values not every flag has a [ __ ] value
and also add there are problems with
flag values that didn't have facts also
and parameters and operators operators
we decided that there are parts that are
either neither a parameter of flag or
sub comment those are very special
characters that would also carry some
information for the common things so for
example piping passing arguments or this
Double Dash that indicates that after
this double dash we no longer give
commands to give options to the command
and for the named entities we decided to
start with IP some parts obviously you
could say just like a new strike X for
that but as I told you not really so for
example we have this example of IP in
between slashes and we also saw any
examples in our logs that sometimes this
is actually a version so it's like it
looks like a IP because they're four
numbers and dots in between but it is a
versioning of some product of some
program and also I feel like words or
strings were used in names of lots in
names of files so here comes we are
coming to the training we use
conditional random fields because it
takes
they take sequences into cutter they
take contacts into consideration because
they were consequences and for us it was
very important that they are explainable
because after trying a CRF model we have
like top transitions and top features
that are part of the are parts of this
model and also it works on a very small
amount of data so for the first
proof-of-concept it was very important
for us to try something like that and
the training looks like this
from the sentence we create sequence of
tokens we label it obviously
but from the tokens we also create
sequence of features and features are
very very important in the CRF algorithm
so here are the examples for part of
speech we for example used if a given
token is the beginning of a common line
if there is a slash in a token length of
a token so as you can see those are all
boolean but also string like and float
integer values as treated as features
and for named entities we used part of
speech tags coming from a previous step
of hall training and for example if
there is a dot in a token how many dots
there are etc etc and it is very
important for training CRF to use
features for a current token we are
thinking about and the previous one and
the next one so it really takes the
context the whole context into
consideration and we create features for
that so for example we were for a part
of speech we were checking the length of
a current token the previous token and
the next token etc etc so the results
for part of speech tagger we trained
using over 2,000 of common lines from
different days and we tested on some
amount of command lines and we actually
had to use a very different month
because we didn't want to fool ourselves
in our data we see that command line is
coming from range of the protocol days
are very similar to each other because
what people are doing the same job on
their computers for example not even
week so for train data we wanted to
differentiate it a bit so we used a
completely different month and we are
obviously happy with the results but I
was more than happy when we were like
looking through the validation data set
and looking at the errors that Parker
was doing and we saw that actually it
was better than us because during
annotation really is a human work and
sometimes tired and so we make mistakes
and it was actually like saying there
should be actually flag value not a
parameter etcetera etcetera so we were
really really happy to see yay
it was starting to fix I work so as I
told you from CRF art after training we
can get transitions and features that
are important for a particular model so
we could see that the model learned that
after a comment there should be a flag
or a parameter or maybe a sub comment
but not a flag value because the weight
is and also after a flag there should be
a fact value or another flag but it is
highly unlikely that after a flag there
is going to be a comment parameter or
some comments so it has learned
something and regarding the named entity
recognition model we were also happy
with the results obviously we had
annotated to data once again so we used
over 2700
common wines for training and we could
see on the features that we're getting
from the model that it for example
learned that well label all means that
it's me neither an IP or a part
obviously so it's restaurants that alpha
has alpha so it's like the future if
this token contains some characters that
are like coming from work so problem now
you see and so obviously if there is
some alphabetic character is neither an
IP or port and after IP we often saw :
and when there is a dot in African it's
probably an IP other ports not a normal
like not 99 editing so here comes
real-life example if you like I can show
it to you like online I fired it up but
how it looks like we have an example we
want to do and we just get part of
speech tokens out of it and then feed it
to the tagger feed get the features and
feed it to the tagger
as you can see it has learned and it
performs really good command a flag
another flag with a flag value and then
two parameters and we can
after having tax part of speech tax we
can go with it further into named entity
recognition and I'm sorry a lot of
tokens so I split it up into two cones
so it probably it's correctly recognized
that there is IP used so I would really
like to thank you lea and Susanna were
actually sitting here and for doing this
project with me we're doing it together
and big thank you too much in Bostick
and father what they were helping us
with annotation and all the knowledge
sharing and also to Philip all shocked
he was our consultants regarding
cybersecurity issues in this project
thank you
thank you for your presentation and now
questions
yeah hello thanks for the talk
could you say a few words about how the
model was deployed actually so who uses
it in what setting and what was the
consequence is how did it impact the job
of those guys I think in the war room
okay so it's still actually a proof of
concept so we are working on like making
it bigger and bigger and actually
retraining it with more data so it's not
used in production yet but I've showed
it to that like people sitting in a room
and they are really happy about it they
are not going to use it directly we have
to like implement it for example in our
backhands for example for normalization
purposes or for this statistical
analysis of uncommon flag and the flag
values used in very like normal comments
so they put the example of get status
with different weird [ __ ] [ __ ] values
and then further we would like for
example give them information that
before they are well I knew event a new
log comes in and they don't have to look
at the comment line at the beginning
they just have a flag oh there is a like
usage of this weird command or usage of
this IP or part so like it's it should
aim to simplify they work in a way that
it's going to be quicker but we still
didn't diplomat it's on production
another question
thank you for the talk do you have an
idea how to actually address the problem
of multiple Commons appearing during the
time so to have some some way to address
this problem right now
so we are actually doing such analysis
without using this like framework of NLP
already in different in very different
ways and so we yet didn't think about it
but sometimes you can think about like
the command is separated by a pipe and
this is actually like two sentences in a
one sentence so this is our next next
step to just like connect and see how it
behaves because well this is like some
higher-level analysis and we just wanted
to build this like fun fundament of the
of the whole project because well
obviously you could do it for English
like analyze the whole text whole
document sentence after sentence but
underneath if you have this tokenizer
you have this part of speech tagger you
have this effective and all the
dependencies between words and somehow
somewhere during the code some in the
models and we don't have that so we
decided to start with this proof of
concept it's fundamental then we can go
further
okay so thank you for your presentation
why you
[Applause]